the only thing we can be sure of about
the future is that it will be absolutely
fantastic
everybody welcome to this special
episode of into the impossible
recently the university of california
san diego institute for the arts and
humanities
commemorated the 100th birthday of primo
levy with a symposium
remembering his life and the example he
said of uniting scientific and literary
cultures
primo levy was a chemist a writer
and a survivor of auschwitz he said that
stitching together molecules taught him
to stitch together words
and ideas this episode of into the
impossible is dedicated to the memory
of primo levy
today we're going to have a conversation
with dr luca lignani
he's a research fellow at the scripps
institute and he studies
among other things the origins of life
and how that is affected by
the chirality of
molecules so why don't you introduce
yourself
tell us a little bit about you and how
you get into this work
yeah hi everybody uh yes my name is
luca legnani and this is the the field
i'm studying so i'm a
postdoctoral fellow in the uh in the
group of
professor blackmond and what we are
trying to understand or to collect more
evidence is about
is uh the general picture is the origin
of life so our life started on our
planet
and more specifically our uh as the
origin of homocorality so
why the molecules that are part of our
body and
part of the body of of many living
organisms
why they have a specific chirality and
how
these started so luca you you're
obviously italian
primo levy was italian so you that you
know you know about him
what was it about his work that inspired
you
uh yeah well primo lady is very famous
in in italy and worldwide
mainly because of his work uh about the
holocaust during the
second world war but primo levy was also
a chemist and the uh he was inspired by
chemistry so
you wrote many short stories about about
chemistry
and i'm pretty uh sure i would say that
also
with these short stories with his
writing you also inspired
different generations of chemists
for sure in italy but i'm also pretty
sure uh worldwide
tell us about how your work intersects
with this interest you had in primo levy
um
well primo levy wrote probably regarding
chemistry's most famous
book is the periodic table in which he
has different short stories and every
story
is dedicated to a specific element of
the periodic table
but we don't have to forget that also
primo levy was uh one of the main
other big topic he was interested about
was also region of life that's a little
bit
the uh branch of research i am uh
i'm involved too um so he wrote
for example the short stories his own
maker that was published
in 1971 in which primo levy imagines to
have such a
long memory by which you can go back in
the past and
look at the different stages and paths
that brought
a simple bacterias evolving to more
complex
uh animals so also bringing it to the
form of
of a human another interesting short
story is for example carbon
that was also published in the uh in the
70s
and in the short-term carbon he uh
takes the molecule he takes an atom of
carbon and he follows it
into different uh into different stages
so
in the atmosphere as a molecule of
carbon dioxide
then ending up in the
in a plant for example or in different
animals the literature the the writing
and the the the the metaphors and the
um the style of his writing
it inspired a lot of science a lot a lot
of uh scientific investigation
uh i think it's both ways so it's for
sure as you're saying
these is writing interested many
chemists many scientists
and for sure many have been inspired by
his work and also the other way around
so
primo levy was as i said it was a good
chemist
and he well knew what was going on in
the scientific community and
more specifically in the uh in the
chemistry community so it was also
it took inspiration for many of his
short stories by
the scientific discoveries and by a
reaction elements
and molecules and we can find them in
many of the of the short stories he
wrote
so here's uh one of your slides that
talks about the carbon cycle
yeah exactly uh the the short stories uh
carbon that was published in the
uh in the 70s in 1975 um
follows the uh the journey of an atom of
carbon as i said
into different living organisms such as
like plants animals
but also in as a non-living matter so
for example in the atmosphere
as carbon dioxide or in the ground
and yeah in the 70s also other authors
were interested
in in the origin of life so for example
uh
carl sagan uh as in the in the first
slide
uh he tried to imagine the origin of
life
in uh and he condensed the the the story
of the
of the of the universe in a one-year
calendar
um and he condensed the
origin of life only in one in one month
so right here at uh ucsd we have a
legacy uh which was the famous
uh miller yuri experiment which is
trying to prove
abiogenesis right uh yeah miller and
yuri were
they later on became professor here at
ucsd
and they were the first that could
confirm the hypothesis of operin so
operin was this
russian biochemist and he was the first
one who suggested that
molecules could grow into a
more complex structure and more complex
molecules
and miller and uri that's what they
could they could prove so basically they
took
some sort of these apparatus and they
started refluxing
and applying uh electrical charges
to a mixture of inorganic and simple
matters
in organic molecules such as for example
methane
ammonia hydrogen and by refluxing under
a warm temperature for many days
after analyzing the content of these uh
of these apparatus they could find more
complex molecules such as for example
amino acids
so this was the first time that somebody
could prove a little bit the
hypothesis that was formulated like uh
30 years before by operand by this
russian
biochemist so do you buy it i mean is uh
is is abiogenesis
uh something that has been
proven is there more evidence for it or
less
there are definitely more evidence so
since the
experiment in the 50s by uh miller and
yuri also more uh
even more complex molecules have been
built
into uh conditions that are called
uh probiotically plausible so like into
for example warming them up and by
applying them
uh electrical charges so
yeah even more evidences are have been
collected since the
since the 50s for sure the experiment of
mila yuri is the
the most famous one but there are uh
even even even more
than than those so so your work gets
gets more into this uh showing this
slide which is the
the concept of chirality or the
handedness of molecules
so first tell us what chirality is
uh yes coyote it's what interests me
but again it's also a big topic about
which primo olivios was very interested
and he was
so interested that he also wrote his
master thesis as an
undergraduate student at the university
of uh turin so
chirality is actually um or well we can
describe
an object as being a chiral when
it it's not possible to superimpose it
on its uh mirror image so the classical
example
that chemists use to describe
a chiral object is the example of one
hand because if we take for example the
right hand
the mirror image of it is going to be a
left hand but we cannot superimpose the
two images
one on to the uh one on to the other so
also for this
for this reason we usually speak about
uh
right hand and left hand uh molecule
another
easy example can be also the one of a
chair so if we take a normal chair
this is a non-chiral object because
we can take the the mirror image of a
chair and superimpose
onto it but on the other hand if we take
a chair like a conference chair with a
side table on the side in this case we
cannot
superimpose the image of this kind of a
chair
onto its mirror image so in this case we
are in the in in the presence of a
chiral
object and chirality is an extremely
important
property in chemistry because
if we have an atom of carbon that's the
fundamental atom in the molecules of
life
and this atom of carbon is connected to
four different
group of atoms or to four different
molecules
then we are in the presence of a chiral
molecule
and it's very very important because
usually it
interacts with living organisms in two
different ways
according if we are using a right hand
chiron molecule or a left one
so very famous for example example of
chiral molecules are the one of
thalidomide
so right thalidomide was commercialized
uh
many years ago like in the 50s if i'm
not wrong
and it was commercialized as as a drug
to fight the adenosia in pregnant women
the only problem is that the molecule
that was active that was having the
benefit of combating this nose effect
was the right hand molecule
and the problem the main problem was
that this kind of molecule was not
commercialized as a pure
so it was not just commercialized the
right hand molecule but because it's
just
easier to prepare it also costs less it
was commercialized as a
racemic mixture so 50 of the right
four molecule and 50 percent of that
left for molecule
and the left uh molecule
uh was then
was uh has been seen that was uh
causing a teratogenic effect onto the
babies that those pregnant women
were waiting for so just to be
clear about it there's no difference
in the physical properties of the
molecule
exactly exactly the same melting point
boiling point
same solute properties same
you know uh chemical uh formulas
chemical periodic table same example
exactly you're right they are they have
the same physical chemical properties
so this part of the this part
this combines why they are so
interesting and also so difficult to
work with
so the main difference is that they uh
interact in a different way with other
chiral molecules so that's why
living organisms that are full of chiral
molecules
uh they if we take
other chiral molecules we are going to
see them interacting in a different
way with for example with our with our
body with the body of
of the living organisms so here's
another example
uh yeah exactly this is the the other
example so uh
methamphetamine the left form of the of
the molecule is sold as an
over-the-counter
drug as a nasal decongestant
so this kind of molecule can be easily
both in
many pharmacies what is not so easy to
get your hands on is actually the right
form of this molecule
because the right form of
methamphetamine has actually affected
as a recreational drug
so if you want to get this then you will
have to ask for example yeah walter
white in the uh
in the very famous tv series breaking
bad to prepare
this for you so primo levy was
a good chemist and he knew that in a
chemical reaction so if we are if you
want to prepare like uh
uh to to uh uh
a product formed by the left and the
molecule and the right hand molecule
if we are in the absence of a chiral
template so if we don't have any chiral
molecules
into our reaction mixer what we are
going to prepare is a so-called aracemic
mixer so
50 of the left four molecule and 50
percent of the right
four molecule but in the other hand if
we are in the presence of a chiral
template so of a chiral molecule
we are going to pre to to to be in the
present so it's possible it's
not always occurring but it can be
uh that we are forming 60 of one
molecule and 40
of the other or to the point or where we
are in the uh with 99 percent of a left
molecule and
one percent of the uh right one
and how these parts are very interesting
where they're
linked together with origin of life is
because
as i was mentioning before our body and
the body of
mostly all the living organisms are
formed by chiron molecules so for
example all the sugars that we are using
are in the right hand form and the amino
acid that we are we're using are in the
left and the form so for example amino
acid forming protein
or sugars that are part of dna
and rna but now the the big question
uh that again primo levy was asking
himself in the short story
asymmetry in life is how it's possible
that starting from simple molecules
uh we could form only
one hand form of the molecule so the
question is not if we can take
water hydrogen and methane methane for
example and bring and
forming for amino acids because that was
as we discussed before was
proven already by miller and yuri but
the point is that
how at the origin of uh of the universe
if we
didn't have any chiral template in it
why
life is formed by uh 100 percent
one form of the hand molecule so again
why why we are in the presence only of
right sugar and the left amino acid and
not the other way around so
why we don't have like uh razemic
mixture in the living organism or why we
don't have the other way around why we
don't have
less sugar and right amino acid for
example
that's also the the very big and general
question
chemist nowadays in order to address
this question they
divided this process that would have
potentially brought to the formation of
again left amino acid and right sugar
and all the other molecules into
different steps
so from a condition in the pre in where
where we had a racemic mixture so 50 uh
each
of the two molecule we need some events
that would bring
to an er enhancing reach the
form of the two molecules so asymmetry
breaking so
going from 50 50 to 5149
then following this step we would have
to increase this kind of
imbalance that we're formed so going
from 51.49 to
maybe uh let's call it 90 10
and then now these uh molecules here
once they are enriched to this level
how they are finally enriched to the 100
percent
form of uh again for example in this
case right sugar and left amino acid
and now this chiral information is even
transferred into more complex molecule
such as dna or proteins
one of the idea for what concern for
example the first step the symmetry
breaking
was already published discovered in the
70s so
it has been seen that if we take for
example a racemic mixture
of this amino acid valine so 50 percent
of each
and if we are irradiating this mixture
with the
left circularly polarized light
we are going to degrade this mixture but
we are not going to degrade the two
molecules at the same way
so at the end of the process we are
going to be in the presence of a little
bit more
of the left form of the amino acid
versus the
right form so it's not a big difference
it's going to be just one percent
but is important to start the whole
process
what's interesting is that um left
circle circularly polarized light was
not probably present
present in the probiotic earth but
what has been discovered is that uh from
the
space dust that is falling on our
on our planet some amino acids are a
little bit
unreached so there is a little bit more
of the left form
of this amino acid again it's not a big
uh amount it's just like few uh a few
points percentage of this ee that's a
parameter that chemists
use to describe the chirality but this
is also
pretty fascinating because it's it might
suggest that origin of life actually
as an origin out of our planet
part of the um for what concern the
second steps there are different
uh processes that have been uh described
that have been discussed uh many of them
for example
take in account different
crystallization processes
so crystallization in a is a
purification method that
all the other chemists use in their in
their lab
to purify molecules but they also might
be involved
in this process of growing
these uh impaired this imperative in the
uh in the mixture of right and left
left molecules so for example if we take
a suspension in which there is in which
there are
amino acid derivative in the uh
dissolved in the in the solvent so in
solution
but uh also in equilibrium with their
solid form
if we start from a little bit of an
imbalance so from 51 for example of the
left form versus 49 of the other one
and if we start steering very in a very
vigorous way this kind of a
suspension after a few days we are going
to be in the presence of sixty percent
and forty percent of the uh other form
so we are growing into these uh
imbalance
and if we keep steering our suspension
for
uh even more days and for example after
two weeks we are going to be in the
presence of only the left
form of the amino acid so this
is for example uh an experiment that
would
suggest how it's possible to go from a
51
49 imbalance into a much
bigger one the last step of this process
is also how
to connect all of those uh reaction so
how all of these reactions uh
communicated
uh together to bring
at the end the the molecules that are
forming life so again
for example sugar into dna and amino
acid into
uh protein so we have what we are doing
for example right now
is to take uh molecules such as amino
nitriles
that are likely to be present in our
periodic heart
and if we have a asymic mixture of them
and if we are uh if we are inducing them
to basic condition
we are going to form amino acid
derivative in a 50 50 percent
mixer so in a racemic mixture but if we
again if we in this kind of reaction we
are in the presence of a chiron molecule
and not
as a random one but right sugars what we
are going to form
is more of the left form of the amino
acid
so why do you think this happens is it
it seems like there's a there's physical
processes
that tend towards this handedness
with with no enzymatic or no
bioactive uh process
that needs to happen um yeah exactly
one of the in these in these hypotheses
in these reactions that we are working
on we
we think that uh enzymatic reactions
were not
quite there because at that that point
was like much
forward in the origin of life uh
pathways so uh all of these reactions
and and
and uh um and processes they actually
are occurring because
of the interaction of chiron molecules
that were already there
so uh starting again as i showed in the
in the presentation so starting from
this little imbalance
it it's then enough to have a little bit
more of one form of the current molecule
to give the to to bring this current
information and to propagate it
into uh uh into different molecules so
so in your lab how do you study this how
are you breaking this down um we have
different reactions different processes
that we are
that we are studying uh one for example
i i show it right now
it's taking is understanding how
sugars and amino acids are communicating
together
because again also all this chiral
information is
transferred to different molecules so
again in this case the two
most important ones so sugars and amino
acids there are also
different studies in which they involve
the
uh polymerization for example of amino
acid into
more complex structures that are called
peptides and now for example the current
information of peptides
is also transferred to other reactions
and this uh this last slide you have
it's it's kind of asking it's kind of
begging the question
that that we started with yes because
the
the the origin of life is uh of course
it's part of a big picture
and uh the um the original of homo
chaority that's what we
discussed today uh can also maybe help
us to address
our original fly for cured so if it
occurred by
a sequence of pre-ordained events so in
a deterministic view
or as a series of uh random events
in a stochastic point of view um
of course we can also not exclude that
intelligent design played a role in the
origin of life but yeah as scientists we
feel that this would be
a pretty boring answer to give
and in in your career what is
uh what's got you excited where do you
want this to lead
i think for example there is much more
to do
for what concern sticking to a region of
life or what concern for example the
different uh
metals so metal catalysis is actually a
big
a big field in organic chemistry but i
have the feeling that many
uh the role of different metals into the
reactions at the origin of life and now
has not been uh studied enough
so this would be for example also a big
big
uh picture to try to to get more of
an idea about uh i would see simple
simple metals
so iron our copper uh all these
uh metals at the at the role at the at
the origin of our of our planet at the
origin of of life
on the on the earth so we just had a
tour of our cosmology lab and you saw
the
polar bear telescope and you saw the
small aperture telescope that's headed
for the simon's observatory
where we're looking at polarity of
the universe's oldest light the cmb or
cosmic microwave background
how do you uh feel about that did you
see some
some comparisons some parallels to your
work
uh yeah i would say definitely like the
uh
polarized light might of course as a
as as a as an influence in the in the
uh uh indica in the chirality that that
then is part of our of life of of life
of
of our life and of of life of the of the
living organisms
so there are many many many possible
connections
uh i think it's it's a matter of
understanding if also the
uh the the the the energy of life is
like
enough to uh to be transferred then to
uh to a process to reactions
where would imbalance again i would
repeat a little bit myself but
if it's able to imbalance into
one direction or the other our
asymmetric mixer so again if we are in
the presence of a 50
50 a mixture of the two molecules if we
if this uh this light is
possibly inducing the either the
degradation of one or the other one
or the uh formation of one process
versus the other to go in the in in
either one or the other direction well
luca i want to thank you for being
into the impossible thanks for the
opportunity giving us some insight into
your work
and into the work and life
of primo levy in celebration of his
100th birthday
imagination.ucsd.edu
for the arthur c clark center for human
imagination i'm stuart baldo
thank you for listening the only thing
we can be sure of about the future
is that it will be absolutely fantastic
you